thinking about your next vacation what
if I told you there's no need to wait
for next year thanks to the retro land
theme park an animal crossing new
horizons five-star amusement park start
your day at the teacup ride while
parents sip on their morning coffee next
catch the superstars of wrestling as
they Duke it out in the smash arena then
grab a snack or beverage at one of our
many dining options located in the
center of food court and enjoy live
music as you do spend your afternoon
relaxing by the pool don't forget the
kids playground which features a rock
climbing wall sandbox and more then cap
off your day with some fun and games at
the retro land arcade now get ready I'm
about to give you a full breakdown of
how the park was created demolished and
then rebuilt again from scratch people
of the Internet retro records who are
here your guide to family-friendly
content in the world of video games so a
couple of weeks ago I published this
video and to be honest I was pretty
proud of the theme park we'd created
what if I told you I'd completely
demolished nearly all of the old theme
park and built a new one from scratch
well that's exactly what I did and now I
just have to share the new and improved
version with you if you stick around to
the end you'll see just how it has
completely changed in so many different
ways guys it's it's crazy now this just
so happens to be my favorite spot on my
island but I'm curious to hear from you
guys what creations are you most proud
of so far or what are you hoping to
create let me know down in the comments
I'd love to hear what you all are
creating and by the way guys our island
is now officially a five-star island
obviously others hit this milestone much
faster but my son and I have really been
playing at our own pace and not getting
into too big a rush and I could not be
prouder of where we're at well as from a
new theme park this is the focal point
of our five-star island and it all
starts with the entrance you can see one
of our first upgrades right from the
start with the new metal red ramp which
replaces the old blue wooden one we had
previously also much more organization
to the flowers this go-round
what's funny is I joked last time about
us having two mini flowers but I
actually used nearly all of them up here
in the revamp they're just way more
spread out as you'll see throughout the
video you've probably already noticed we
switched to the Imperial fence as well
which I think matches the ramp into the
park quite nicely
as you enter you'll see the two
marketplace flags on both sides and also
a stone arch as you make your way
forward two booths on either side as
well with one booth having magic hat and
the bingo roller drum thingy yeah I
included two fountains on either side of
the entrance as I think these fountains
look really good in a variety of
locations I have several of them on my
island and they're definitely one of the
most versatile items you can use now as
you make your way to the central area of
the amusement park you'll quickly
realize the entire area has now been
based around this central hub which
serves as a food court I also put the
teacup ride right smack in the middle as
I feel it's such an important item to
the overall space a lot of the items in
here I'm kind of stretching to make work
with a theme park setting but the teacup
ride really sets the tone nicely and it
also has the musical element which I
think is perfect in the previous video I
mentioned that the food court was my
favorite area so I've moved it front and
center here and have also provided more
seating this time all of our food
options are still here pizza popcorn
cotton candy and more restrooms and
trash cans are still important as always
however we found a nice little spot over
here to the side to tuck them out of the
way
after all you need convenience of them
nearby your food area but you really do
not want to be smelling them as you sip
your morning coffee the music area is
still there on top so folks hanging out
in the food court can enjoy some live
entertainment now to the left of the
food court we have the wrestling ring
which now features a table for the
broadcast announcers
as well as an entry line to handle all
the traffic flow for this top attraction
oh and don't forget those Smash Bros
logos on the side you'll also get a
glimpse of the Godzilla monster here as
you wait in line in addition to a nice
view of the sea
maybe it's my history of playing hours
and hours of sim theme park as a kid but
how awesome would it be if we could
actually invite others into our island
charge admission and have them use our
attractive purchase food okay okay I
realized those expectations are way too
high but hey I could dream come on
Nintendo so let's make our way back
across the food court now and head over
to the swimming pool now this area is
probably the one that's changed the
least from last time I just didn't think
there was all that much we could improve
on here other than organizing the
flowers a bit better the playground area
is larger now and we've added a
rock-climbing wall in addition to the
slide bouncing horses and sandbox
next we come to the fortune cookie stand
in a nice little Train Set here and a
little water fountain there in case
you're feeling a little bit thirsty
after having those fortune cookies and
finally we have our new and improved
arcade section now I've heard there are
plenty more arcade machines in the game
so this gives us a nice spot where we
could easily expand later on if needed
overall I think you can see that we have
way more organization this time round
everything was based around that central
foodcourt hub and also using the teacup
ride as our main attraction right there
in the middle of course as with anything
in Animal Crossing I'm hoping that this
is just the beginning I'm hoping I get
even more items that we can use in this
wonderful space at this point I'm just
hoping Nintendo will add even more
themed Park items to the game such as a
ferris wheel or even a roller coaster
would be amazing if it happens but I'm
not holding the breath well if you've
gotten any new ideas at all from this
video be sure and hit the thumbs up
before you go and if you want to see
more videos like this in general then
hit that subscribe button so you won't
miss any of our future videos and I'll
know just how many of you out there
really want to see more that's gonna be
it for me today if you're ready to take
your own trip to retro land and visit
retro raconteur dot-com today that's
retro raconteur dot-com